Roberts with us in Virginia hey Robert
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hey Dave
how's it going better than I deserve
what's up that's what I hear so I'm all
mixed up as far as the order of the
delay you described things I started
listening to you instead of paying
attention I mean I've got pretty good
control but I'm not like in water so
I've got a I've got an emergency come on
good I've got to turn life insurance for
a million dollars on myself I've got the
only debt I will have left is my life
schooling and my house okay so we owned
both the cars we have everything good
how much how much is here in London 30
and how much is in your emergency fund
47 write a check today it's so here's my
struggle as I'm thinking about this all
right here's my struggle I want to pay
the house first because the snowball
effect that you talk about isn't worth
it in my mind I'd rather pay more
interest up front for the school loan
and pay off the house for this that's
that's my struggle here because well
here's the thing here's the thing we
don't we don't use the snowball effect
on your home the snowball effect is in
baby step two where you pay off all of
your consumer debt you only have one
left and that's the student loan debt at
the end of the day you owe for you you
owe 30 would you say 30 mm-hmm 30 on the
student loan okay and how much is owed
on your home okay and so why would you
want to keep 30 around for all that time
while you're paying off 250 because I
can do it in 10 years it's like are you
can do it in 10 minutes if you take care
of these you write a check today you can
you can be debt-free on on the in 10
minutes on the still on
student loan and then you're freed up
from that and you've got you're down to
then baby steps four or five and sit
well you got to go back to rebuild your
emergency fund all the way up but then
you'd be on baby steps four five and six
and you'll be working on your retirement
working on your kids college if that's
necessary and then and then I didn't
start reach over and start smackin that
house you only got one thing left to
just punch on and that's the house at
that point and there is a power in this
process Robert to focus mm-hmm and the
fact that you're getting rid of this
mosquito in comparison to the elephant
it gives you your focus that's exactly
right and Dave you take what you know
Robert you can take what European on the
student loan debt and start to throw
that at the house after it's paid off
after you get that emergency we said
something Robert you said I'm all mixed
up but I'm now listening and paying
attention well I hope you're listening
and paying attention because if that's
the case then you're gonna write to
check pay off the student loan debt get
this thing out of your lie you won't
regret then you will not you I promise
you won't regret it
yeah you you're gonna feel okay that's
done the Ox checked now let's get the
emergency fund rebuilt because we just
drained it down a little bit too low 47
over 30 right only 17 sitting there yep
and then he's we need to build that back
up and then let's make sure we should
get the emergency or get make sure
putting only 15 percent into retirement
yep doing the kids college that's baby
step 5 and something towards that and
then reach over and start knocking that
house out you're gonna knock the house
out in no time if you'll do that but
this is very progressive it's very
focused it is it's a little bit linear
in the sense that you do this before you
do this before you do this and there is
a you know 30 years of case studies here
at Ramsey on why you do that that that
clarity that clear path it just cleans
up your brain clothes and there's
there's this power to this focus that's
again we see it in all the data points
with a millionaire study